KEILAR ON THIS "NEW DAY".
WE'VE GOT BREAKING NEWS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
NO ONE HAS LOST THE STATE OF
ARIZONA MORE THAN DONALD TRUMP.
HE KEEPS LOSING AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
EVEN WORSE THAN HE THOUGHT.
FOR MONTHS, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
HAS CLAIMED THAT THE SHAM
PARTISAN AUDIT IN ARIZONA'S
MARICOPA COUNTY WOULD REVERSE
THE RESULTS AND SOMEHOW DECLARE
HIM THE VICTOR.
A DRAFT REPORT OF THE SO-CALLED
AIR QUOTES AUDIT BY A GROUP
CALLING ITSELF THE CYBER NINJAS
FOUND NOT ONLY DID DONALD TRUMP
LOSE BUT HE LOST BY EVEN MORE
THAN HE REALIZED.
HE IS AN EVEN BIGGER LOSER THAN
THE FIRST TIME AROUND.
THE NEWS ISN'T WHAT PROVES JOE
BIDEN WAS THE LEGITIMATE WINNER
OF ARIZONA.
IT ALREADY WAS.
HE DIDN'T NEED AFFIRMATION OR
CONFIRMATION BY THE CYBER
NINJAS.
THE RUTS OF WHICH, AND MAYBE THE
GOAL ALL ALONG WAS TO RAISE
DOUBT, TO MAKE PEOPLE BELIEVE
SOMETHING MIGHT HAVE BEEN STOLEN
WHEN IT WAS NOT.
AND THAT QUEST CONTINUES.
DONALD TRUMP DEMANDED THAT
TEXAS, A STATE HE WON,
INVESTIGATE ITS ELECTION.
OVERNIGHT, JUST EIGHT AND A HALF
HOURS AFTER GETTING HIS MARCHING
ORDERS FROM HIS LEADER, GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT COMPLIED WITH HIS
LEADER.
THE STATE WILL NOW AUDIT THE
2020 ELECTION RESULTS IN FOUR
COUNTIES.
AND ONE RESULT OF ALL OF THIS
INTENTIONAL DOUBT, VIOLENCE.
WE SAW IT ON JANUARY 6th.
AND ALSO THIS MORNING THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION HAS
ISSUED ITS FIRST SUBPOENAS FOR
TRUMP ADVISERS.
>>> A FEDERAL WARRANT ISSUED FOR
BRIAN LAUNDRIE IS NOT CONNECTED
TO GABBY'S DEATH.
WE ALSO HAVE NEW INFORMATION
ABOUT THE LAST TIME IRAN DRY SAW
HIS PARENTS BEFORE HE VANISHED.
WE HAVE REPORTERS COVERING EVERY
ANGLE, BEGINNING WITH KYUNG LAH
IN ARIZONA.
TELL US THE LATEST THERE WITH
THIS CONFIRMATION THAT REALLY
DIDN'T NEED CONFIRMATION.
>> Reporter: WELL, WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, BRIANNA, IS THE
DRAFT REPORT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
RELEASED OVERNIGHT.
IT HAD BEEN FLOATING AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL FOR A FEW HOURS
WHEN, YOU KNOW, SUEDLY LOCAL
PRESS STARTED TO PRINT IT OUT
AND WE ALSO HAD ACCESS TO THIS.
IT IS THE DRAFT OF WHAT WE ARE
EXPECTING WILL BE A FINAL REPORT
PRESENTED TO TWO ARIZONA
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE.
AND THAT WILL BE THE FINAL
REPORT.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING
IN JUST HOURS.
BUT LET'S GO OVER WHAT'S IN THIS
DRAFT REPORT.
IT IS A HAND COUNT THAT YOU GUYS
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
AND THAT BIGGER LOSS FOR DONALD
TRUMP, JOE BIDEN PICKED UP 99
VOTES PER THE CYBER NINJA COUNT
VERSUS WHAT MARICOPA COUNTY
INITIALLY FOUND.
DONALD TRUMP LOST 261 VOTES.
YOU HEAR JOHN TALK ABOUT BEING A
BIGGER LOSER, THAT'S THAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IMMEDIATELY DREW A
STATEMENT FROM THE MARICOPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SAYING THIS.
THIS MEANS THE TABULATION
EQUIPMENT COUNTED THE BALLOTS AS
THEY WERE DESIGNED TO DO.
THE RESULTS REFLECT THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS.
THAT SHOULD BE THE END OF THE
STORY.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS JUST NOISE.
NOW, I READ THROUGH THIS ENTIRE
REPORT, AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THE REST OF IT, THE DEPTHS OF IT
IS REALLY A LOT OF CONSPIRACY
SPAGHETTI THROWN AGAINST THE
WALL.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
EXPECTING LATER TODAY HAD THE
FINAL REPORT IS PRESENTED.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN TO
ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE MARICOPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
BILL GATES.
>> I CALL IT A SHOW TRIAL.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT ALL THESE
HAVE BEEN UP TO THIS POINT.
IT'S A SOVIET SHOW TRIAL.
DEMOCRACY IS NOT THE WORD I
WOULD USE.
A THEATER SHOW OF AN ATTEMPT TO
STEAL AN ELECTION, OR AT THE
VERY LEAST TO SOW SIGNIFICANT
DOUBTS IN OUR ELECTION SYSTEM.
.
>> SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ANTICIPATING TO HEAR LATER
TODAY.
IT WILL BE THE FINAL
PRESENTATION, THE END NOTE OF
THE ARIZONA AUDIT.
>> THE END OF A PERIOD OF
THEATER THERE IN ARIZONA.
KYUNG LAH, THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.
WE WILL BE COMING BACK TO YOU
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
>>> DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN TO
DESTROY CONFIDENCE IN AMERICA'S
ELECTIONS IS ALSO TAKING HOLD IN
TEXAS.
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT CAVE TO GO
TRUMP'S DEMANDS.
THE STATE AUDITING FOUR COUNTIES
COVERING HOUSTON, DALLAS, FORT
WORTH AND PLANO.
AND SARA MURRAY IS JOINING US
NOW TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
WHY DOES DONALD TRUMP WANT
AUDITS IN A STATE HE WON?
.
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
OBVIOUSLY, NONE WILL CHANGE THE
ELECTION.
IN THIS CASE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS STILL THROWING
THESE TEMPER TANTRUMS.
HE SENT THIS LETTER TO GOVERNOR
ABBOTT.
THIS PRESS RELEASE CAME OUT OF
BLUE FROM THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE SAYING, OH, WE
HAVE ALREADY BEGUN AUDITS IN
FOUR COUNTIES.
HARRIS COUNTY, DALLAS COUNTY,
TARRANT AND COLIN COUNTY.
THREE OF THOSE WENT FOR JOE
BIDEN.
ONLY ONE OF THOSE WENT FOR
DONALD TRUMP IN THE 20th
ELECTION.
AND I WANT TO JUST SHOW YOU HOW
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS STILL
SPINNING THIS BIG LIE.
IN THIS LETTER HE SENT JUST
YESTERDAY TO GREG ABBOTT, HE
SAID WE'RE QUICKLY RUNNING OUT
OF TIME AND IT MUST BE DONE THIS
WEEK.
LET'S GET TO THE MOM OF THE 2020
ELECTION SCAM.
WHAT HE WAS ASKING FOR WAS THE
TEXAS GOVERNOR TO PUT
LEGISLATION IN THE SPECIAL
SESSION TO SAY WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE AUDITS.
IT SEEMS ABBOTT WENT ONE STEP
FURTHER AND SAID THESE ARE
ESSENTIALLY ALREADY UNDER WAY.
WE ARE 10 MONTHS OUT OF THE
ELECTION.
THERE IS A LOT OF TIME TO RELIT
FATE THE RESULTS AROUND THE
ELECTION IF THERE WERE CONCERNS.
THEY SAID THEY RAN A FAIR
ELECTION.
WE ARE SEEING THIS PRO LIVE
RATE.
WE ARE SEEING IT HAPPEN IN
PENNSYLVANIA, WISCONSIN.
THIS IS REALLY A BIG LINE FOR
REPUBLICANS RIGHT NOW AND A WAY
FOR THEM TO SHOW THEIR LOYALTY
TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT
>> IT'S VERY REVEALING ABOUT
WHAT THIS MAY ACTUALLY BE ABOUT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT.
>>> JOINING ME NOW IS BEN
GINSBURG.
YOU CALL WHAT HAPPENED IN
ARIZONA OVERNIGHT A CRIPPLING
LOW FOR THE CLAIMS THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAS MADE.
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY, JOHN.
IN ARIZONA, THEY BROUGHT THEIR
PARTISANS IN TO DO AN AUDIT.
THEY CREATED RULES THAT SHREDDED
THE NORMAL CREDIBILITY THAT YOU
GIVE TO AUDITS.
THEY TOOK MONEY FROM PARTISANS.
AND STILL THEY COULD NOT PROVE
THAT THE ELECTION WAS FRAUDULENT
OR RIGGED OR THAT JOE BIDEN
DIDN'T WIN.
SO ALL IN ALL, THIS WAS THE
STATE WHERE DONALD TRUMP HAD HIS
BEST CHANCE TO PROVE THE
OUTLANDISH THEORIES HE'S HAD
ABOUT THE ELECTIONS BEING
FRAUDULENT OR RIGGED AND HE
SWUNG AND MISSED YET AGAIN.
>> MAYBE THEY CAN GET ALABAMA TO
FLIP TO JOE BIDEN AT THE RATE
THEY'RE GOING.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THOUGH, BEN,
I THINK IF ONE IS DISCUSSING
THIS AS IF IT IS AN AFFIRMATION
OR CONFIRMATION OF JOE BIDEN'S
WIN, WE'RE DOING IT WRONG.
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE DOING OR
I'M DOING HERE.
THE ISSUE HERE IS THIS AUDIT HAD
NO GROUNDS TO BEGIN WITH.
THIS WAS A SHAM FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
>> IT WAS.
BUT IT WAS THEIR BEST SHOT.
SO HERE'S THE SILVER LINING IN
THIS AUDIT AND IN WHAT THE OTHER
STATES ARE DOING.
I THINK IT'S CRAZY FOR
REPUBLICANS IN OTHER STATES TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENED IN ARIZONA TO
DO THEIR OWN AUDITS.
BUT THERE IS A SILVER LINING,
WHICH IS 30% OF THE ELECTORATE
DOES NOT BELIEVE OUR ELECTION
RESULTS.
THEY ARE BELIEVING DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE IN A
DEMOCRACY.
EVERY TIME THEY'RE GOING TO TRY
ONE OF THESE SHAM AUDITS IN THE
STATE, THEY'RE GOING TO FIND THE
SAME THING, WHICH IS THE RESULTS
ARE ACCURATE.
THAT'S THE WAY YOU ARE GOING TO
GET TRUMP PEOPLE TO STOP
BELIEVING THE BIG LIE.
GIVE TRUMP HIS CHANCE TO PROVE
IT.
THEY HAVE SWUNG AND MISSED EVERY
TIME SO FAR.
>> MAYBE.
ALTHOUGH I HAPPEN TO THINK THE
QUESTIONS THEMSELVES ARE WHAT
PERPETUATES THE BIG LIE.
THE QUESTIONS ARE BASELESS, BY
AND LARGE.
THE WAY THEY RAISE IT.
THE FACT THAT THEY THE THE AUDIT
IS WHAT HELPED FOMENT THESE
QUESTIONS IN PEOPLE.
THE AUDIT, TO AN EXTENT, HAS
ALREADY SERVED THE GOALS OF THE
PEOPLE BEHIND IT, WHICH WAS TO
CREATE THE QUESTIONS THAT NEVER
SHOULD HAVE EXISTED TO BEGIN
WITH.
.
>> IT HAS.
BUT AS MORE PEOPLE SEE THAT THE
AUDITS ARE INDEED SHAMS THAT
THEY DON'T PROVE WHAT DONALD
TRUMP SAID, IN FACT, THEY REFUTE
WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAS SAID, THEN
THAT'S THE WAY YOU GET THE 30%
TO TAKE A SECOND LOOK AT THE
WHOLE IDEA.
AND, LOOK, THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
REALLY EFFECTIVE STUDIES IN
MARICOPA COUNTY ON THE VOTE.
AND IT SHOWS THAT IT WAS
REPUBLICANS WHO ABANDONED DONALD
TRUMP AT THE TOP OF THE TICKET.
REPUBLICANS WON DOWN BALLOT.
THEY DID NOT VOTE FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
AND SO THAT'S THE PHENOMENA
WHERE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
EVENTUALLY SAYS WE'RE LOSING OUR
BASE.
WE'RE LOSING OUR SUPPORTERS WITH
THIS CRAZY TALK.
WE MAY BE APPEALING MORE TO
DONALD TRUMP'S BASE, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO START LOSING ELECTIONS.
SO THIS IS ULTIMATELY A BALLOT
BOX DECISION TO GET RID OF THE
BIG LIE
>> BEN, IT TOOK -- IN TEXAS,
EIGHT AND A HALF HOURS, EIGHT
AND A HALF HOURS FOR DONALD
TRUMP TO WRITE A MEAN NOTE
SAYING TEXAS SHOULD AUDIT THE
ELECTION AND GREG ABBOTT
BUCKLES.
NOW THEY ARE DOING A FORENSIC
AUDIT OF FOUR COUNTIES.
IT DOESN'T SEEM REPUBLICANS ARE
WILLING TO STEP UP.
>> NOT YET.
IF THIS AUDIT, WHICH IS TWO
REPUBLICAN COUNTIES AND TWO
DEMOCRATIC COUNTIES COMES UP AS
EMPTY AS THE ARIZONA AUDIT, THAT
IS